但是老婆女儿对他的耐心已经用完了。
已经不打算等他帮女儿交学费，也不打算等他什么了。人家那边。
您开始过日子了。
而且他之他之前无在无效尝试的时候，还去惹过那对父子，他的形象已经在那完全坍塌了，他就是个无赖。
他在那边就是个无赖。
那对父子现在是好人。
对吧是可靠的男人。
所以他在升职呃，就升为正式警察，得到表彰之后去找妻女又被撵出来，等于是可以往下打他一下。
然后真正把他打趴下呢，可以用一件什么事儿呢？他之前在夜摊放走的那个小流氓，其实。
是逃犯。
又行凶了。
杀人了。
比如说。
那这条命。
是不是得寄在他头上？
放走的那个小流氓杀人了。
这条面就进你头上了。
他自己一看那个照片，他就明白了这条命在我身上。
当然啊你可以你写到这儿的时候，你可以根据情形做调整啊。
可以不要是条命。
可以是一个。
就看你看程度啊，你如果觉得这里需要他惹一个大事儿，那就是一个花季少女被杀了，被奸杀了，先奸后杀，杀完又奸。
那他扛了。
他在观众里扛的罪孽就最大。
你说我想扛的稍微轻那么一点点，那就是一个小伙子为啥？
小伙子被杀了，在观众那里扛的罪孽，比比一个少女要低一点，或者一个老太太，真的这种话说出来很恶心。
命生命其实是平等的，但是在心里呀。
真的就是这样。
就是一个小伙子被杀了。
没有一个少女。
被杀了。
来的沉重。
你说我不想他抗命也可以，那就被砍成植物人。
你说那。
植物人有有点。
反正有点那就一个少女被强奸了。
没死，养家了。
反正这个你自己去调整啊。
但不能再清了。
不能再听了，你不可能说我放走了那个当年当时在我背后欺负人那个小流氓，我因为我自己那个伤心在那喝酒，不想管他。然后呢，他跑出去抢了别人的钱包，你这个就。
你这个观众就会觉得那没什么，钱还能再挣，你懂我意思吧？就不能再轻了。
不能再听了。
至少要么弄出一个植物人，要么。
常见，而且植物人是个小伙子，都太轻了，植物人也得是个少女。
反正啊。
在这儿把它打下来。
就是这个。
把它打下来用什么呢？
就是他之前放走的那个。
相当于他的原罪啊，他的开场戏就给人放走了那个。
杀人了，我们先说杀人了啊，好，理解杀人了。
再加上他。
在妻女那里。
的打击。
彻底被他在青云那里彻底被判了死刑，彻底被扫地出门，彻底毫无希望了。
他决定。
去找那个。
他放走的那个。
歹徒那个胸徒。
那个穷凶极恶的。
欺负他妈卖面小夫妻的那那个凶徒。
你如果觉得一个不够，那就三个三个胸图。
团伙。
反正他要去跟那个几个人对命。
他要去跟那几个人同归于尽。
然后在这里在做无效尝试的时候啊，可以他。
设计过一些机关。
明白这个意思吗？
就是他这里比如说他自己设计过炸弹。
或者是他在这里呃处理那个炸弹案件的时候啊，他认为炸弹同归于尽是一个很好的方法。在这里他又把炸弹给。
掏出来了。
这样就是有个呼应啊，他在这里的原罪，他真正想解决的时候，他用的这里的方法，这是一个剧本的前后呼应，这个就会比较漂亮。
那么。
最大的危机就是这个这个生命危险，对吧？
最大的危机就是这个生命危险。
那我们让他在这里决定。
决定这个这个铤而走险吧。
他因为这里受到刺激，在这里决定铤铤而走险，然后开始布置。
他现在是正式警察了呀。
开始做调查。
开始跟踪，你在这里就可以写调查的戏，到处走访跟踪，包括差点抓住其中一个。
跟人家过招了，但是因为自己。
确实。
不能打。
被人打了一顿。
对吧在这里都是可以在这个再转这里。
用这些事情。
往前推推到这个最大的危机就是他翻出了炸弹。
他决定那我本来也是打算死嘛，我想过死，只不过是暂时的升值，让我。
取得了一个叫叫虚假的胜利嘛。
我因为前面前段时间寻死。
行为过于英勇，在这里取得了一个虚假的胜利。就是。
生成正式警察了。
但其实这个并没有改变我的本质，我依然什么都不是。
他通过去找他妻儿，通过跟歹徒。
发生了第一次冲突，他发现我他妈什么还我还是什么都不是。
我根本不是个警察。
我是前面假装英勇得到了一个警察的头衔，我还是假的。
我在我老婆那是假的。
我不是个假的父亲。
我是个假的丈夫。
我是个假的警察。
就是他在这里。
最大的危机之前。
意识到自己什么都不是。
全是假的。
别人对我表彰，假的。
别人给我的荣誉，假的。
我的那些英勇的行为假的。
我甚至都是个假的丈夫，假的父亲。
的警察。
这里就是推到。
在危机之前，把这些主题推到巅峰了。
那他现在最大的诉求是什么？
假警察假丈夫假父亲，我要做一个真男人。
明白吗？
顶到这儿了，这里绝对顶到了。
全是假的，我就要做一个真真男人之前那套炸弹找出来绑在身上了。
对吧同归于尽嘛。
他在地铁那个那个那个银行爆炸案里面得到的那个那个那个灵感啊。
对吧同归于尽不就完了吗？炸弹最好使了，我打不过你怕什么？我只要离你足够近。他之前跟那个炸弹那个家伙谈判的时候得到了很多信息，说你只要离我3米远，我保证崩死你，对吧？那我只要走近他们三米不就完了吗？
绑上这身炸弹。
就去找他们呀。
所以最大的危机已经显现出来了，就是这个炸弹危机。
他要跟别人同归于尽，而且他这时候已经决定要做一个真男人了。你在这里要确保调动观众。
跟他的共情。
让这在这里让观众。
替他觉得不要死，别死别死别死。
然后能不能死？在这里就是最大的最大的危机，最大的考验嘛。
然后导入这里就是增加力度。
增加列度。
他现在有两个对手啊，明面上对手。
是。
那几个。
穷凶极恶的歹徒。
内内核上的对手是他鱼死亡。
到底是死还是不死？
那么你在这里增加列度，就从这两个。
这个这个方向入手。比如说。
在这里。
再次烘托对手的。
让对手也升一个级。比如说对手知道他要他要来了。
对吧他去他以为可以悄悄。
接近对手，但是对手。
已经。
知道他要来了。
不管是通过。
呃，小道消息还是通过他们在警察有眼线，还是通过偶然发现，还是通过他没有经验，不小心泄露了自己的行踪，反正这里让对手知道他的行踪，马上让观众会觉得哎呀耶这个任务更难完成了，裂度更大了，对吧？这是从对手的角度那入手。然后从死亡这个角度入手。
也可以呀，就是那些炸弹。
对吧那些炸弹本来是。
比如说本来是触发型呢。
他又不是炸弹专家，炸弹是从那个地铁炸弹那里跟那个跟那个歹徒学的呀，跟人家学的。
本来是这个这个比如说本来是。
手机触发的。
对吧。
结果去了去到地方，他准备去找那帮歹徒嘛他。
通过调查知道那帮歹徒在哪啊，去了之后发现手机没信号，比如故障。
故障了也可以增加烈度呀，然后他就着急了，他就摁了开始，摁了开始之后一看。
嗯，5分钟，比如说5分钟之内必须走进那那歹徒3米。
等于是把烈度增强，你在这里增导入事件就增强烈度嘛？歹徒知道他要来了，然后他自己还误操作。
又给自己加了一个时间锁，把猎度加强了。
对吧就炸弹这个这个危机列度加强，然后高潮事件就是他怎么。
被打成什么样？
如何冲进敌营，如何接近那些歹徒，如何想办法抱住其中一个的大腿。
对吧。
对方发现他身上有炸弹之后，人家就不揍他了，人家四散逃去，他如何。
这个拖着受伤的身体体力也不如人家怎么样从楼顶往下跳扑到一个人身上。
这里就是高潮事件。
他最后比如说就是。
人家就跑了，但是他从窗上三楼窗上看到。
对方他听着对方咚咚咚咚咚下楼梯，他就等着对方。
哭。
门门的这一瞬间，他从三楼一头栽下去，砸在这个歹徒的身上。
高手把这个核心问题解决的，我带着炸弹砸到你身上，我boss。
我就要怼死你，就要跟你同归一尽。
然后最后结局。
赠送。
赠送自己送看当时的情绪宣泄。
如果到那儿，你觉得需要他死。
那结局就是追悼会。
结局真的就是追悼会。
对吧？
追道会不是需要有几个人。
排他的遗体吗？
对吧就让他老婆女儿还有那一对父子。
四个人嘛抬四个奖，正好像就抬嘛，也代表。
他终于成为了一个。
真正的丈夫。
真正的。
父亲。
真正的警察。
但是死的人。
反过来了吗？她前面是一个假的丈夫，假的警察，假的父亲，但是他要做一个真的人。
最后他得到了什么呢？
得到了他成为一个真的丈夫，真的父亲真的警察，但是死的人。
对吧你如果觉得结局那里需要他死，你就会让他最后结局是追悼会。
当然了，你可以让他活。我说结局是赠送。
不是说现在写不出来。
是没有必要写。因为你要把前面这些事情穿明白了以后，你要看当时的情绪。
情绪或者叫气口。
你感觉哎。
别死了。
那就让他在医院醒过来。
这也是一种方法。
对吧你还要说哇你不行。
最后这个结局我写的太惨烈了，前面他被打的太惨了。
我醒过来也也无法让观众情绪平复，那就让他老婆女儿再回来嘛。
那最熟了。
是不是啊再回来嘛，围在他身边。
照顾他。
当然了，还有折中的办法，就是老婆回不来了。
女儿回来。
对吧。
都可以嘛，女儿终于认可他。比如说她在医院。
受了重伤嘛，昏迷了好几天醒来，然后。
那个那眯蜂的眼。
发现好像女儿来了。
对吧。
女儿在他身边照顾他。
然后女儿在那儿。
跟别人打电话。
吹自己的爸有多英勇，多牛逼。
这种喜剧结尾，然后他听着很满意，不想打着女儿，接着闭着眼装昏迷。因为女儿在吹牛逼，说夸他爹说他爹是英雄，让跟他同学吹牛逼嘛，说你看电视呀，那是我爹。
这种就比较喜剧处理，证明他女儿原谅他。
好吧，我们就暂时可以用这个结局，老婆是回不来了，那那大哥可能也。
人也还行是吧？就长得泪里流气的。
就让他跟那大哥吧，但女儿可以回来。
不耽误啥。
那咱们这个故事是不是就完整了？
完整了吧。
因刚才现想的啊现想的那么。
我们捋一遍啊。
1个序练。
开场戏。
路边摊吃宵夜。
遇到歹徒行凶。
他不管。
这时候观众不知道他是警察啊，注意啊。
明白吗？明白这个处理方式吗？
我们写梗盖的时候，你上来就写这是个警察。但是在剧本中，在大纲中，这个信息是没有透露给观众的。
他就是一个穿着便服。
在路边摊独自喝酒的中年男人。
后面有人打架，他可能看了一眼几个歹徒很凶恶。
不想买单，非说是菜不好，欺负这对。
在路边。
打拼了这对。
小夫妻。
当然你如果想增加烈度，小夫妻旁边在跟着一位5岁的儿子。
正在地上玩泥巴，对吧？
然后被吓得直哭，别打我妈了，别打我爸爸，你看多可怜。
他就是不动心，这时候观众已经有点生气了，觉得哎这个老爷们儿怎么不帮忙？
你下面上再挑逗一下观众，让观众更生气，就是有人报警了，对吧？那个比如说那个摊主那个老板娘，那个女的报警了，报完警之后，他的对讲机响了。
对吧春秀路路口春秀路路口夜市摊有人闹事，附近单位火速前往，附近单位火速前往，所有人都投来有的人投来希望的目光，希望他抱帮助，有人投来好奇的目光啊，原来这是个警察，有的人偷来惊恐的目光，我操，这有个警察，我们是不是应该逃，结果他把对讲机一关？
又打了一瓶啤酒，又开了一瓶啤酒继续喝。
然后那些歹徒继续行凶。
一场戏结束。
结束。
对吧他在之前喝酒的时候，可以尝试给他老婆打电话，但不接。
不接明白吗？
给他女儿也打电话，不接发信息不接。
第二场戏。
去上门。
第二天一早宿醉，穿着之前的衣服，对吧？
然后呢。
跑去找他。
前天头天晚上不接他电话呀，找他老那个老婆和女儿。
结果受到重创。
老婆女儿不光不搭理他，还跟一对父子同居。
他家的女人都搞了，对吧？一个是我跟我结婚20年的老婆，一个是我他妈如花似玉豆蔻年华的女儿含苞。
再创了啊。
被一对父子小流氓给搞了。
父子小流氓溜溜溜起的，对吧？还住着我的房子。
多生气。
不生气，然后女儿问他要学费。
给你机会让你当个爹，让你当回人，你都当不了。
对吧我要上大学。
我要去读音乐学院，实现我的音乐梦想。
对吧？也也不给钱。
出点。
基励时间。
回到警局，本来他妈身上就没揣钱。
一个募捐箱往那咔一放，嗖100块钱，吓一跳。
哪有地震了吗？还是哪有受灾的？
有人英勇就义了。
牺牲了有战友牺牲了。
这有牺牲，你说不出话呀，但是仔细一听。
隔壁县的也不认识。
但是你得捐呀。
而且听说不光捐款，还有抚恤金，对吧？抚恤金是官方发的，捐款呢是战友们的心意。
不牢少钱。
你说自己啥啥也不会，啥也不是钱也没有。
被这个刺激了一下。
然后开始。
萌生了这个念头，说我还不如死了呢。
我还不如死了。
当然如果这里有点突兀啊，你写到这里，你会觉得他如果突然想要自我训知有点突兀，你可以在这里让他打击更大。
就是让他找他妻儿的时候，打击更大，然后甚至让他。
短暂的想寻死。
被彻底打击了，再加上借着酒劲儿，他想跳楼，你可以让他就在楼边站一会儿。
但是不敢跳，觉得他嘛。
胆子小，但是。
就埋下了。
他有可能会一死了之的火种，就是你在这里可以加一场，他走到楼天台边上或者天桥边上。
看了看，有时候觉得还不如一下跳下去，但是呢没敢跳。那么在这里这个激励事件就劲儿就会更大，就发现我既然都动过死的念头了。
我应该以身殉职更好呀。有钱呀，眼睁睁的看着别人，对吧？这都捐款呢，而且各种荣誉。
吉利事件。
然后进展这里就是多次无效尝试。
救火。
爬高对吧？高处有一个什么危机，有人要跳楼。
他冲到高处。
本来是想就是我把他推回去，救了他的命，然后我掉下去，结果往回一救人家，人家把他也拽进去了。
对吧就几次无效的尝试。
全部失败。
一次重大尝试，就是有人。
身上绑绑着炸弹，想做大坏事儿，想炸人想行凶。
然后呢，阵仗很大，这是第一次大场面啊。
各种警车、狙击手、特警队谈判专家。
对吧围观群众他本来是协警嘛，本来是周边。
这个这个负责蓝群众的。
想想去他妈的棍一扔。
冲上去。
冲上去了。
结果给这歹徒吓坏了。
给这逮徒吓懵了。
放弃抵抗了。
他莫名其妙成了英雄。
对吧在这因素发生改变了，他不再是个协警，不再是一个没有人理，没有人搭理的人了。他成了一个受表扬的、受表彰的身为正式。
警员的一个人，让他享受短暂的胜利，短暂的。
那叫什么虚假胜利嘛，虚假的胜利，虚假胜利很容易做啊。就是在这里，比如说你前面铺一个他们警察局的前那个接待处啊，或者是办公室办公那个总务处呀，办公室主任是个女的，本来呢不太搭理他，然后叫错他名字。
眼里也没有他，但是呢长得风韵犹存，他其实老喜欢多看人家几眼，现在突然对他刮目相看，对吧？觉得你是个英雄了呀，就是通过这种事儿，你前面插一笔在这里反一下，就可以让他享受这个虚假的胜利，享受的更。
更更更具象化。
然后这些虚假的胜利包裹着他，但这些始终都是虚假的呀。办公室那老娘们对你再线殷勤，他也不是你老婆，他也不是你女儿呀。但这虚假的胜利先让他享受享受。
甚至开始也有就是那个以前啊以前就是协警跟协警一块吃饭，警察跟警察一块吃饭，吃的东西也不一样。现在警察下班之后，我说哎，今天晚上上哪去吃涮肉，搓一顿，就是哎老张老王老李一块去啊，哎，一块儿。
然后他转头看看之前的协警兄弟们。
跟着警察那一堆去吃了，对吧？这这都是虚假胜利，这里可以加上这种戏。
那就然后呢。
呃，把这个虚假给他。
戳破把这个泡沫戳破。
呃，去去找他老婆孩子。
还是不搭理他，甚至更不搭理他了。因为交学费的日期已经过了。
而且你刚生，你也拿不拿不出现钱嘛。
他就会。
彻底的被。
击溃。
一切都是假的，并没有实质性的改变。
然后这时候最大的打击，我们说最大的打击。
需要来自于原罪，需要来自于他本身，不可能是说横空出来一个坏人，横空出来一个坏人，他没有那么大的愧疚感。我说了要知造愧疚感，那就用第一场他目睹，但是放掉的那一个歹徒或者是几个歹徒。
重新做完了。
烈度你们自己去掌握这几个人是。
杀了人了。
还是奸杀了少女了。
还是奸杀了好几个少女了。
还是就监了。
对吧？
你们掌握一下，反正这几个人做出了一个让他无法原谅自己，无法走出心里折磨的一件事情。
你通过你的共情，通过你对这个角色的共情，他进展到这里犯了一件什么事情？
让他觉得无法原谅。当然了，也有丧心病狂的编剧，直接让这几个人把他女儿强奸了。
有啊有这么做的。
有这么做的不是。
不是不可以啊，你写到这里你自己去体会啊。
自己去体会这个烈度，明白这个意思吗？
你需要力度再大。
你觉得哎这几个人强奸奸杀小女孩，我也觉得烈度不够。我想让这个逼再嗯懊悔，再懊恼，内内心更折磨，那你就强奸了女儿。
这烈度你们自己去掌握啊，我是觉得。
我我感觉就是如果是我的话，我是比较倾向于杀人。
因为咱们这个戏。
最基本的主题还是生死。
所以我的感觉是让他们杀了人。
好，这里你自己去选啊。
就是让他们。
呃，让这个这个虚假的胜利彻底被击溃。
除了他老婆孩子继续不搭理他。
然后呢，跟那个一对父子越走越近，幸福美满，让他觉得他自己是一个假的父亲。
假的老老公，假的警察全部是假的。
最大的打击来自于他放走的那个他放走的那个人坐下掏天罪行，就是提醒他，你就是个假警察。
你什么被表彰，你什么英勇无畏。
你就是个玩忽职守假警察。
提醒他。
那么在这里。
这一切虚假。
让他决定。
做一回。
真男人。
自己犯的罪自己补。
找到之前行凶的那几个人。
跟他们同归于尽。
完成所有的事情找到那几个人给给他闯下的祸填坑，然后呢又实现他之前的那个。
原计划同归于尽。
那原计划暂停是因为虚假的胜利嘛，现在既然是个假的胜利，那我也要坚持原计划呀，而且又出了这么大的事儿，那我就跟那几个人同归于尽，把炸弹翻出来了。
对吧然后就开始调查，找那几个人。
然后我说的增加烈度。
增加猎读的方法，让那几个人知道他在找他，让那几个人无比凶残。
对吧让他自己呢在关键时刻掉点链子。
掉点链子有很多方法，比如说因为。
这个再次喝酒闹事儿，让人把。
枪啊刚配的枪还没使明白呢，又给他收了。
对吧。
或者是给他配了枪，但是没有配子弹。
橡皮子弹什么的。
你想办法嘛给他增加难度。
增加烈度。
然后最后这个。
核心问题。
核心的这个这个高潮场面，就是高潮那场戏，那一定是。
孤胆英雄跟那几个歹徒搏斗嘛。
我说过就是。
被打的很惨之后。
他孤注一掷，可以从三楼直接跳下去，扑倒那个歹徒压在人家身上引爆炸弹嘛。
然后结局赠送纯赠送。
对吧可以躺在医院的床上。
身受重伤，昏迷了好几天，但是微微一睁眼的时候，发现他女儿。
在吹牛逼，在对外吹牛逼，说我爹老牛逼了，在他发现他女儿在拍抖音，拍她昏迷的样子。然后发我父亲是个警察多牛逼多牛逼，对吧？在拍抖音嘛。
拍抖音相当于年轻人在。
对外炫耀。
然后他。
继续闭眼。
装昏迷，但是嘴角露出了笑容结束。
干净利索。
这就是。
咱们之前。
举过的八要素的呃举过例子的那个八要素故事，一个想要殉职的警察。
换成。
1个训练。
八要素都在我们说八要素怎么用的？
八要素怎么用的？
就是他身份在。
1个序列中的变化，它的欲望在10个序列中的变化。
他的动作在10个序列中的变化，它的问题，它的阻力，然后正负价值在10个问题，10个序列中的角力此起彼伏，负加值占上风，正价值占上，负加值占上方就是这8个要素在。
你。
的10个序列里面。
是要产生变化的。
而且变化的落差越大。
就变化的越彻底走到越走到对面。
拉伸的张力越大，你的故事就越好看。
这就是。
全部的。
10个序列。
我们通过。
一个将要殉职的警察。
给大家举例说明。
咱们这节课就先讲到这儿吧，这节课时间也不短了。
但是。
但是大家知道10个序列怎么写了？
就知道大纲怎么写了。
就越来越接近我们的剧本了。而且这10个序序列里面不再有那种描述的话了，不不要再给我写那种无法变现的，无法变成画面的话了。
全是我们刚才说的是1场戏。
十呃10个关节全部都是可以变成画面的。
好吧，大家。
记住。
1个环节，然后。
考虑一下我们。
这十个例子。
布置的作业。
你也不用自己创作了，你就把我说的这个一个将要殉职的警察这10个关节自己去写一下。
写一个大纲。
好吧。
十个序列不是只有十场戏啊，是十件大事儿。有的这个一个序列，比如说他这里多次尝试。
的时候那就是好多场戏呢。
包括他这里铺垫什么的激励什么的，都不止一场戏。就这个回到警察局，也不是说一场戏就完事儿，先回到先去派出所所长办公室被呲一顿，对吧？然后再被那个么呃跟同事再怎么着，然后捐款怎么着，而且开始不想捐想混过去。
你不要直线思维啊，说啊去回去捐款，然后把钱交上完事是他可以先想躲呀。
哎，我捐过了吧，刚才然后大家又查一遍，你没捐。
自己去想辙好吗？就每一场每一每一个关节。
不止一场戏。
自己去把。
1个关节。
理明白。
写写出一个大纲，就写这个故事。
好吧。
好，下课。